reactions were mixed after felix psychic
ad was announced the winner from
jubilation to consternation people
certainly made their feelings known the
opposition leader wasn't expected to win
the presidential vote in the Democratic
Republic of Congo but he edged out his
main rival putting the country on course
for its first democratic transfer of
power in almost 60 years since
independence I know many of you will
find it hard to accept but I say it with
sincerity I pay homage to President
Joseph Kabila President of the Republic
today we must no longer consider each
other as adversaries but rather as
partners in democratic change in our
country some believe sick akt1 by
cutting a deal with President Joseph
Kabila who's clung to power for 18 years
although Kabila's preferred candidate
only came third
the man expected to win Martin feyo Lou
is among many contesting the results
these results do not reflect the truth
of the ballots this is obviously
unacceptable electoral fraud of a nature
that will provoke general chaos across
the country meanwhile the country's
influential Catholic Church is already
questioning the vote
it says official results do not match
the outcome compiled by its 40,000
observers at all polling stations across
the troubled country the church has also
called for calm still many people are
upset in Goma many did not hide their
feelings
amid the potential for unrest we don't
want this Machiavellian sale of the
Congolese people's power
laughing God yep legally we're going to
call on article 64 of our constitution
in the end though experts say it will be
up to the country's Constitutional Court
to rule on the vote well for more on
what happened today I'm joined by Nick
Alavi
he is in kinshasa tonight he is the
country's director in the DRC for the
open society initiative for Southern
Africa his organization supported the
monitoring of last month's election in
the Democratic Republic of Congo Nick
good evening it's good to have you on
the program
what did your election monitors conclude
I mean do the numbers that you have do
they support a win for Felix chickadee
good evening and thank you for having me
generally speaking when you have a look
on the report from the divers the
electron observation mission the
election took place in a generally
peaceful manner whatever certain factors
affect the fairness of the process for
example some candidate were represented
to companion some constituency some
people loved alive in the circumstance
access to public media was not equal for
those in the majority and the opposition
many claim on use of public resources
and operability for the purpose of a
companion without function in citizen
physican lack of consensus on the voting
machine and also a huge number 1.2
million of Congolese prevented to vote
in bennyboo chamber in UNB because of
insecurity and Ebola so generally
speaking this is what electron motion
observation report on the electrode a
and the process before the election so
what so what is your conclusion then was
was the result that was announced
earlier today is it the correct result
this is difficult to to answer to that
question according to Electoral
Commission
any light of the the figure that the
Electoral Commission published today
felicitate is the winner of the
presidential election unless there is
some critical and real others that are
controlling this assumption this is what
we should take from this election from
now you should remember that the primary
mission of the observation mission was
not to publish any results even if there
is the specific case of the Catholic
Church who did a sort of you know
pollard voting tabulation and which
openly interrogate and the the quality
and the content of the reserved
published by Shane
yeah that's an important point to make
there were 40,000 election observers for
the Catholic Church and they say that
there were irregularities with the vote
counting we're gonna have to wrap it up
there Nick a levy in kinshasa tonight's
Nick we appreciate your insights thank
you
you